hey hey Leute ganz herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen
Video eine nicht lachen Challenge sch
verkackt ganz neu oh wir machen ein ganz
Video ohne lachen
okayer grüßung einfach hey Leute was
geht ab ich bin Sandra ohne du bist
Sandra und Laa hey Leute ich bin Sandra
und das ist Luca und das bin ich
undkommen nicht lachen ich habe heute
irgendwie Lachmuskel
an ist ihr was ziemlich wildes sogar
promy Chicks wie Billy eilishch finden
meinen willly
stylishch nicht
lachen wir machen heute so okay ja was
bekomme ich wenn ich ein Video nicht
lache verloren okay leute das ist das
alte Auto und wir gehen zum neuen Auto
re Z
1 ja hier ist VW ab Elekro noch mal das
gleiche Auto vor 10
Jahren wer steht denn daneben seine
Freundin die Nummer ein ich bin der
beste ich bin der krasseste keiner ist
krasser als ich keiner ist besser als
ich ich bin Jeremy fragance die Nummer 1
parfüikone die den Lehren von Jesus
folgt redest du auch mal so zu selber
wenn du verr WST ja nur halt auf
Latein blö immer hinter mir also icheh
hinter mich und guck erst auf die e was
passiert und wie ist es für sie na ja
mich kann man totfahren ich habe schon
Platz auf dem
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Friedhof ist das so ein Ding wohl bei
älteren Leuten dass sie sich schon so
ein Platz auf dem Friedhof reservieren
so sollen wir uns jetzt auch ein
reservieren nebeneinander wo willst du
begraben werden ja bei ME iner Heimat
ich will in Köln ja
okay K wir doch
nicht wenn wir uns eine ganz andere
Stadt aussuchen müssen wo würden wir hin
äh ballorca
okay da sind wir wieder world indoor
bows Championships Turnier wir haben
Nick Brett an der Reihe
Durchschnittsalter der Zuschauer seht
ihr about to die ist aber auch so
gewollt die soll noch mal was cooles
erleben bevor es denn zu Ende geht so
die Ausgangslage ist super knifflig aber
mit Nick Brett haben wir eine der
wenigen Menschen die das Spiel elden
Ring beendet haben ohne einen Schaden zu
nehmen das ist sehr B
privat ist Twitch Moderator von Montana
black hat sich heute noch sein lieinggrk
geholt den G
[Musik]
rasber wieso findest du SAS lustig
kennst du das Lied nicht ne menschlich
ziemlich
[Musik]
abstoßen
wieso findest du sowas lustig das ist
wieso ist das
quer
keung ich glaube da sind paar Videos
drin die ich eigentlich in
meiner
[Musik]
Selbstbefriedigung wenn ich jetzt Treff
gehst du
schlafen
London du hast gerade selber gesehen
Schicksal wollte so ich wünsche dir eine
gute Nacht vergiss deine Probleme und
jetzt
[Musik]
GI hat ja ein anzu wie bei C und A von
der Stange SEAG dir so wie ist was noch
hat ja ein Anzug wie bei C und von der
Stange Kanal Tuning Mafia seid die
heftigsten ja ja heute Laufwettbewerb
und h sind ein paar NPCs
unterwegs mein kleiner Bruder kommt
gleich mein kleiner
bra hey hey hey wie heißt er er heißt
Justus Justus
justususer wie Legende ist
das wirklich NPCs
ne hey danke man hey danke hey danke m
hey danke he danke hey danke he
danke hat bisschen gedauert die T mir
auch bisschen leid haben doch Spaß ja
aber die sind so die denken die Kinder
machen so haben Freunde an den aber die
lachen die eigentlich aus basically ja
ich würde die auch auslchen ich verstehe
also was mich jetzt aber gerade hier
extrem aufregt ist dass S den Weg
komplett neu gemacht haben der andere
war noch gut das verstehe ich auch nicht
diger die haben den Weg hier neu gemacht
ich verstehe diesen Typen nicht hat der
Alzheimer warum der er reagiert auf ein
Video wo er selbst drin ist und eine
Meinung sagt und sagt dann zu seine
eigene Meinung ja stimmt sehe ich auch
so ja würde ich auch so machen B du vom
dumheitsbaum gefallen oder Waser
klettergü
ü sag mal Gurke sag nicht diger Gurke du
[Gelächter]
GZ Joker
gesetzt und
[Musik]
dann
ich glaube glaub das ist echt oder fake
erstmal habe ich das glaube ich auch in
die falsche Playlist gepackt die falsche
Sammlung der falschen Ordner aber das
ist echt also das ist wirklich in in Las
Vegas dieses Ding dieses s ich weiß
nicht ob das wirklich stimmt mit diesem
Gesich da
aber also ich kann mir das selbst no
nicht so ganz vorstellen D das irgendwie
ich habe auch Videos aus dem Flugzeug
gesehen bluch hier mal ein wo einer aus
dem Flugzeug dieses Ding gefilmt hat wie
das dann so den Flieger angeguckt hat
und so was die da für eine Stromrechnung
auch gerade sagen Alter ich Date wir
haben eine Klimakrise eigentlich ja aber
ich bin pro Klima Spaß pro Klima ich
glaub jeder ist pro Klima oder ne ich
find Klima gut jeder findet es nein ich
find ich sag nichts
mehr das habe ich nurenommen ich vor
einem Jahr ich vor einem Jahr wir waren
nämlich mal in nissbon und diese Stadt
ist
gottlos du siehst bei bei Apple Karten
steht 100 me irgendwie eine Minute
dauert esinzugen aber weg ist so und
Google Maps die berechnen ja keine
Steigung und die Check nicht du
kommstter nicht fah Kel durch diese stad
das ist die absolute horrorstadt dazu
Leben gr kan der wel guck dir den an
auch züchten
sollen
gut meine Damen und Herren an der Stelle
würden wir heutige nicht lachen
Challenge auch beenden wir haben mal
wieder super hingekriegt nicht zu lachen
Sandra wie würdest du die Klimakrise mit
sechs Worten
beschreiben Greta tonnberg
dann ja scheiße das Positive ist ich mag
Wärme die das dritte ist Müll das vierte
ist Abgase das fünfte ist Motorschaden
das sechste ist haltet die Fresse Ciao
kako du war das danke dass in sechs
Worten jetzt beschrieben was waren es
jetzt mehr oder wie waren weniger als se
aber ist okay übrigens deutsche LC und
ich gehen auf Tour ja die seht hier die
Termine eingeblendet wenn das
Jaag okay tschüs